hey everybody welcome to the 13 o'clock
podcast this is episode nine and we did
a thing about a serial killer last week
the original night stalker and after we
did that I kind of got interested in
other sort of lesser-known serial killer
cases but I thought I'd take it back to
the Victorian era and this topic
actually got the idea from a really cool
British miniseries it's on Netflix if
you want to watch it it's called murder
maps and it's kind of a cool show where
they talk about it's from the Victorian
era - I believe World War two was the
last one and they kind of talk about the
most spectacular crimes that happened in
London around those time periods and
they mentioned Jack the Ripper but you
know since so much is known about that
they kind of went off in different
directions and talked about lesser known
ones and one of the cases they talked
about is actually one of the guys I'm
going to talk about today and they
mentioned the other guy I'm going to
talk about today and I wanted to put
these two guys together because they had
a lot of weird similarities they're both
convicted serial killers well both were
poisoners they you know they use poison
for the murders that they were finally
convicted for and incidentally they were
both considered suspects in the Jack the
Ripper case so this is a possibility
that one of these two guys could be Jack
could have been Jack the Ripper sure
where they believed to be they were
believed to be Jack there or they were
believed to possibly be Jack the Ripper
back in those days - right yes
okay yes uh one is more likely than the
other okay but um you know and there
were obviously a lot of suspects I think
at the time eighty people were detained
but the first guy I want to talk about
the is this going to be the case of
George Chapman now interestingly George
Chapman was the man that inspector
Frederick Abril
who was the main Jack the Ripper
investigator and if you saw the movie
from hell that was the character that
Johnny Depp played a Fredrik Adam
abberline actually thought that George
Chapman was the most likely suspect and
even though there are some other
suspects that are kind of likely to I
mean this guy just by his movements
alone it kind of makes you really
suspicious okay this guy he was actually
Polish born in Poland and George Chapman
was not his real name that was an alias
he went by several of them his birth
name was Severn kozlovsky I hope I said
that right
sorry Polish people and he in the end he
was convicted of killing three women
although they think there might have
been more now he was actually a
surgeon's assistant he trained under a
surgeon when he was a kid in Poland and
you know surgeons assistant nurse back
then would have just been you know
sticking leeches on people and [ __ ] like
that but um you know since some people
at the time thought Oh Jack the Ripper
must have had some medical knowledge
blah-dee-blah so you know that ticks
that box there now he moved to London
they think in 1887 or 1888 now if you
know anything about the Jagger Jack the
Ripper case you know that the Ripper
murders took place in 1888 and George
Chapman specifically not just moved to
London he moved to Whitechapel where
they haven't where they happen right now
he didn't live super close to where the
you know the crime scenes but he did
live in that area now he had a wife back
in Poland but evidently he said [ __ ] her
and he left her back in Poland because
when he got in London he married another
Polish girl who was there named Lucy
Badescu I think bigamy was kind of
common back then there was no way yeah
there was very to really check
especially country to country yeah so he
probably figured hey why not you know
here's another now it should be noted
that his wife Lucy was other than his
original polish wife his wife Lucy was
the only woman he was involved with that
he didn't kill oh that's just like so I
think she was alright but he had two
kids with her also and his original wife
found out and she got pretty pissed
obviously two one back in polo the one
back in Poland right out about I don't
know if she did anything about it like I
don't know she like you know marched
into London gone you know [ __ ]
or anything like that but you know so so
even though he had a wife in London he
started taking up with other women he
had about four mistresses would he do it
he would introduce them as his wife I
but he worked as a surgeon's assistant
or bird type of thing alright yeah so he
took up with these women he said they
were his wives some sources call them
his common-law wife whatever um three of
these women mysteriously ended up dead
now no one noticed anything like he'd
they didn't suspect anything at first
his first two victims were named Mary
spank was the first one and oh my
goodness oh sorry
gesundheit yeah and Bessie Taylor was
the second one and they died from
quote-unquote illnesses so no one
thought anything about it you know oh
they got sick they died right however
then he took a mistress named Maude
marsh and same thing happened with her
she's very young very pretty girl um I
believe he was running a pub and she
worked there she was a lot younger than
him and her mother lived there as well
she came down with some mystery illness
and you know he seemed very you know
doting on her and he was all upset and
calling doctors and trying to figure out
what was the matter I don't have any
idea what could be wrong with her took
her to the hospital whole nine yards
they had no idea what was the matter
and so she just got sicker and sicker
and her mother called in another doctor
yeah and I don't think he wanted her to
call it another yeah he's like my
doctor's fine you know the other doctors
gonna say the same thing that my doctor
said you know it's fine but the mother
was like you know I want her to get
better so she called in her own doctor
second opinion to get a second opinion
which you know reasonable enough right
now this other doctor came in and at
first he wasn't quite sure what was
wrong either he conferred with the first
doctor and they're like maybe somebody
could be poisoning her yeah because the
symptoms were kind of similar to arsenic
poisoning
now Maude Marsh did end up dying and
because of the mother suspicions because
of the doctors suspicions George Chapman
was arrested and they actually found out
about the other two women and had them
exhumed yeah they found out all the dead
women in his past yeah so you know his
other two mistresses and they did an
autopsy too they did and they found out
that these three women had indeed been
poisoned the poison he used was it was
actually um over-the-counter you could
buy it at a pharmacy it was called
tartar emetic and it has a metallic
element in it called antimony which is
very poisonous in high doses but like I
said you could buy it it was for colds
and flus and things like that and it
turned out that they found out that
George Chapman had bought a very large
supply of tartar emetic from a chemist
in Sussex and he had been administering
this to the women over a long period of
time so it looked like a long illness
and then finally they died and an
Timothy poisoning is very very similar
to arsenic poisoning very painful very
you know very lingering death death yeah
very unpleasant and
it turned out because of the mother's
suspicions because of the doctors
suspicions George Chapman was arrested
after they did the autopsies and found
the poison and he ended up now I guess
and I'm not sure like what the law wat
like why the law was like this but
apparently he could only be tried for
the one murder I don't know if it was
because the other two women were too
degraded like to for it to stick I think
Victorian era law was pretty convoluted
well and because I think the law in the
UK at the time I mean if you killed
somebody they pretty much is hung your
ass they might walk around so it's just
like well one murders as good as 20 it's
like you're gonna hang you anyway simple
so so he actually only ended up being
convicted for the death of Maud Marsh
that's all they needed that's all they
needed was like I said you know so they
hanged him at Wandsworth prison in 1903
now the weirdest thing about this guy is
that he didn't really have a particular
motive no motive the only time he got
any financial gain I mean you know a lot
of times these poisonings it's for
financial gain usually um the only
financial gain he got that they know of
was one of the women left him five
hundred pounds
that's nothing which was a lot of money
at the time but not a fortune
by any means why not worth commits
murder he was a businessman right he had
he had a pub yeah right yeah he wasn't
broke and I mean you know he was a
skilled person and so it would seem like
the other two women he didn't get
anything out of it could it have been
Munchausen by proxy see that's what I'm
thinking because maybe he got off on on
caring for these sick women and the
attention that it afforded him for
people going oh poor guy and like you
know his what well people thought it was
his wives but they were actually
mistresses but yeah because they the
doctors said that he did seem genuinely
concerned yeah and he seemed very
grief-stricken when they died I'm
thinking it most of
Munchausen by proxy it might have been
because initially I would have thought
maybe he was just a sadist
maybe he enjoyed watching women suffer
maybe however like you said every all of
the witnesses said he seemed genuinely
sad and Jed when they died and he was
upset and he cared for them and in cases
someone in the audience doesn't know
maybe you should explain what Munchausen
by proxy is if you take it for granted
that people know with that yeah I mean
you know you yeah Munchausen by proxy is
basically when someone and in a lot of
cases it's mothers or you know parents
with their children they will
deliberately make their children or make
someone sick because they get attention
and so we're taking care of them about
taking care of them it's you know it's
it's almost kind of like a martyr
complex like Roe look at all of the
trials I have to go through a boat in
Munchausen by proxy they're not actually
trying to kill the kid no but they want
to keep the child ill run so they keep
getting sympathy they keep getting and
in this case it looked like he was in a
way trying to kill although he could
have killed her a lot quicker probably
you that's what I mean because it seemed
like right I mean like I said it's very
poisonous at high doses but he would
just give her like a little bit at a
time no why no why did the inspector
have him as a Ripper suspect me because
what happened one serial killer okay -
an interesting thing was that the Ripper
murders stopped when George Chapman went
to the United States
now when George shot right around the
time George Chapman arrived in the
United States in New York City
specifically there was a murder of a
prostitute named Carrie Brown in New
York City very very similar to the
Ripper murders she was mutilated you
know middle-aged Brothers's you very
Ripper style and certainly at the time
the newspapers in New York Jack the
Ripper arrives on us shores okay right
and it was a big deal it was in all the
media at the time because it was so
similar so there
I mean they're not entirely sure because
like I said George Chapman had a number
of aliases right so they're not sure
exactly they knew he was in the US but
they don't know if he arrived before or
after the Carrie Brown murder but it was
right around the time of that happening
so in general the time line the
inspector investigation showed that
wherever he was Ripper murders happened
and wherever he was not they ceased
exactly okay because they did stop
because he left you know he left for the
United States and the Ripper murders
stopped so that could support the idea
that maybe he had two separate issues he
may ever I had Munchausen by proxy at
one hand and then and then he had
another gig ask the Ripper yeah
killing two different kinds of women
yeah for two different purposes right
and maybe two different forms of
emotional gratification because honestly
it seems to me like the only argument
against him being the Ripper I mean and
like I said there are other likely
suspects as well I'm not saying that he
was the guy but the only arguments
against you're like well serial killers
tend to stick to one modus operandi it's
they don't usually poison their
acquaintances and then go out and hack
up prostitutes however it has happened
it's not impossible
you know usually serial killers will
stick to one method but not always um so
it seems I'm like I said they're not
real sure if he was responsible for the
Carey Broncos are not entirely sure when
he got to New York although it was
around that time but then that gets back
to my hypothesis is he was the Ripper
yeah he had he was a serial killer and
he also happened to have Munchausen by
proxy he wasn't really trying to kill
those women
he was just hiding get Fame or no
attention yeah taking care of them may
be almost a form of it maybe like a tone
meant yeah I'm a caring guy uh yeah
actually that's a good type on trying to
save women that's a good I'm on nobody's
watching suckers kill yeah almost like I
took a weird like Jekyll and Hyde like a
Jacqueline how I did but you know a
killer either way right kill them kill
with your boat it should be noted too
that um maybe it's atonement yeah I want
stranger
so he's sacrificing his own his old wife
and the people that he loved to atone
for the random right who knows something
weird like that that's actually kind of
a good I never thought of it that way
but that's actually how like our Albert
Fish would stick needles in himself yeah
to atone for the stuff that he had done
yeah look at bellever fish you guys
that's a sick [ __ ] but uh yeah
we might do a show on him one day -
that's a sick [ __ ] it should
also be noted that George Chapman's wife
the second one the second one polish one
in London she told Inspector abberline
that her husband would often go out at
night and she didn't know where he was
right and she also said that um I'm not
sure if this is the same actually his
original wife said that he was a wife
beater and it was known that all of the
other women that were his mistresses
they had also complained that he would
beat them up so he was clearly a violent
misogynistic type of guy
his original wife even claimed that he
had tried to strangle her and that he
had a knife under the pillow and that he
said he was going to behead her and she
said he even told her where he was going
to bury her body
what story he was gonna tell like you
know it's helping where she went
and stuff like that so not a good guy no
not a good guy no matter how you uh you
slice it free freak definitely and like
I said you know because they said oh
it's it's rare for serial killer to
change his method blah-dee-blah
there's also some people wonder whether
he spoke good enough English right at
the time you know that he could have
done it um but also again it should be
noted - that his description matched the
description somebody saw Mary Jane Kelly
who was the fifth of the canonical five
Jack the Ripper victims there are
actually 11 murders of women that could
have been Jack Herbert but those five
are the ones that they know were the
same guy she was the fifth one Mary Jane
Kelly and someone saw her with a man
shortly before a murder and George
Chapman's description fit his very
closely yeah I think it was a
description of the clothes and stuff
yeah the Hat yeah yeah um you know yeah
I think they said he looked swarthy and
had a mustache isn't like that room and
so you know so he was someone who looked
like him was seen with one of the
victims so could have been him he like I
said abberline certainly thought it was
him but you know we'll probably no never
know there we'll probably never know
cases tool um so yeah but uh he was
hanged for the three poisonings and that
was the end of that guy now I guess let
me close this the second guy I want to
talk about actually let me take a break
first and then we'll get into the second
guy who was kind of similar in a lot of
ways but also kind of a weirdo and kind
of a dumbass I want to say like he got
caught out of so dumb a survey really
but okay so we're going to take our
first break right now and we'll be right
back in just a few minutes I would like
to take a second and thank subculture
corsets in clothing for sponsoring
project I radio and my show while
listening to my podcast please take a
second and visit their website at
www.att.com/biz gothic steampunk and
pinup clothing shoes and accessories
again their website is subculture
corsets calm or if you're in the
Jacksonville Florida area stop by their
store in The Avenues Mall and if you
like to save money use the discount code
thirteen o'clock when checking out and
save ten percent off your entire order
by the way if you're a curvy girl
subculture did not forget about you they
carry size 4 to 4 X and guys they have
men's clothing and shoes as well so go
shop at subculture corsets calm now and
use the discount code 13 o'clock for a
10% discount ok talking about serial
killers poisoners Jack the Ripper
suspects good and next we will consider
the case of dr. Thomas Neil cream Java's
cream I know which like sounds like make
that name up I don't think he did as
like a porn I was gonna say it
a good hair day Thomas nail cream it's
okay all these people are dead they
can't kill us now yeah but uh so we can
make fun they all it's funny Invicta cuz
of you know if you watch the YouTube
video I'll have like pictures of these
dudes but they all look like that to
this big giant epic mustaches a [ __ ]
guy they had a thing for facial hair
back then they did it was pretty epic
though I gotta say dr. cream uh he's
also been considered by some to have
been the Ripper um although there are
some things against it but he was also a
poisoner um George Chapman was actually
known as the borough poisoner and Thomas
Neal cream is known as the Lambuth
poisoner also a serial killer I don't
think I've ever heard of this guy
yeah have I heard of this guy I don't
think so yeah see I think when we watch
murder maps they talked about the George
Chapman case in quite a bit and they
mentioned this guy but not in similarity
but not not in detail watch but he is on
the suspect list
okay although it probably wasn't him but
you know you never know um he was
actually a Scottish she was from Glasgow
although when he was four years old his
family moved to Canada and so he grew up
in Canada and he was actually a doctor
he went to medical school interestingly
his thesis in medical school was about
chloroform huh which I'm sure would come
in handy much later now the reason why
that he is and this is pretty much the
only reason he's considered other than
being a serial killer the only reason
that he is considered a Jack the Ripper
suspect is that when he was hanged the
hangman claimed that before he died his
last words were I am Jack the yeah I've
heard that story and then he died now it
should be noted that no one else heard
him say that right and you know it would
have been like big bragging rights for
that hey man ago I hang Jack the Ripper
[ __ ] right no I mean so you have
to take that story of the great assault
nothing that could have happened is that
the guy was getting ready to die and in
desperation he might have tried that
ploy to hold up the execution oh yeah
that's yeah
to live for a little bit like wait a
minute wait on your jacket Reverend yeah
I'm Jack the Rialto you the whole story
story you just take this noose out of in
there it could've been that yeah but so
this guy like I said this guy similar
you know similar kind of method of
killing as George Chapman but he seemed
like a sadist but he also seemed like he
was trying to get financial gain out of
it although he went about it in the
stupidest [ __ ] way possible I have to
say and it ended up getting him caught
but he kind of went all over like I said
he went to Canada and he went to
Scotland
and then he went to he actually married
his first wife is wife flora a year
later she got pregnant he gave her an
abortion hmm yeah Wow well he's a doctor
okay
although I don't think he was very good
at doing of course I'll get into that
later but then she later died of quote
unquote consumption no one thought
anything of it at the time but in light
of later events you know they went back
and were like yeah he probably offed her
too but he went to London for his
postgraduate went back to Canada and
then when he was in Canada he had a
little office there a little doctor's
office and a woman named Kate Gardner he
was supposedly having an affair with her
and had apparently he had apparently
knocked her up she was found dead in the
alley behind his office still pregnant
she had been poisoned with chloroform
now cream said I can't believe that set
dude's name do we have to call him that
yeah okay doctor cream that's it that's
like doctor moist not like that so nasty
is such a gross words ridiculous it's
such a gross word but uh so this is okay
now this is the kind of [ __ ] that kept
getting this dude into trouble here's
what he would do he would kill a woman
usually by poison air then he would
write a letter to some prominent person
and say
you killed this woman and I'm gonna tell
the police unless you give me X amount
of money what yeah that's what I work
doesn't mean how would this work how
would this listen I guess he was
supposed to I guess he thought he could
frighten people he's trying to frame
people yeah he was trying to frighten
people into giving him right because
he's like well even if you don't get
convicted you know you'll have to go to
the police and they'll think you're a
murderer and blah-dee-blah and he'll
ruin your reputation or whatever I don't
know what the dude was thinking he was
kind of an idiot
but anyway weird so they found this dead
woman in Canada behind the you know
pregnant chloroform and he was trying to
he'd say how he killed how was he
killing chloroform no just chloroform
two dead yeah yeah okay yeah
the odile dode either he Oded yet poison
ivy poison him with that so he claimed
that a another local businessman had
made her pregnant and killed her no one
fell for it right everyone said no it
was you so he took off to the US as you
would know me
is he that yeah but as you'll see he did
not learn from that
no he did not learn okay next he turns
up in Chicago and he opens up a little
office in the red-light district
okay giving illegal abortions to
prostitutes right which I do needed
service perhaps even though it was
illegal at the time but like I said he
either was not very good at abortions or
he was just super poison happy yeah
because what I'm having the he was first
investigated in 1880 and his this woman
was Mary Ann Falkner and he had
supposedly given her abortion and she
died but there wasn't enough evidence so
he skated on that one
another one of his patients died after
being treated by him and that and in
that case he tried to blackmail the
pharmacist who gave her a prescription
hmm like he wrote her a wrote him a
letter and said you killed this with
your poison that you sent her right you
know what I mean and the pharmacist is
like whatever [ __ ] you did it
8:07 a year later there's another woman
named Alice Montgomery
she died of actually strychnine
poisoning not chloroform and she had had
an abortion also and it was not it was
only a block from his office so they're
not entirely sure they know she was
murdered they don't know if it was him
but he was right there and you know he
was an abortionist he was poisoning
people allegedly so they thought that
was him but it was never pinned on him
what what is the actual motive is there
a motive to that's what I mean I'm not
really sure it's like he tried extortion
and blackmail right I don't know if it
ever actually was there a sexual motive
I don't think so
I mean he did some of the women he was
having an affair was not enough evidence
to say it just kind of seemed like
prostitutes would come in his office
going had an abortion and then he'd be
like here's an abortion oh and I all
poison you too
how about that Wow and then but like I
said but then he would write a letter to
some prominent person to go hey you
killed this girl
or you knocked this girl up and killed
her so he gives me money are all called
extortion yeah but like I said I don't
think it ever worked huh ridiculous I
don't think it ever worked now so he had
apparently killed all these women up to
this point and had gotten away with it
however people got more suspicious when
a man turned up dead what should tell
you something right there so this was in
this was in Illinois actually he was
still in Chicago at this point was in
1881 man named Daniel Scott and he
turned up dead after he had gotten a
prescription from dr. cream doctor moist
after he had gotten a prescription
because Daniel Scott had epilepsy
so dr. creams like why help you with
that here's a prescription and then he
died hey killed all right now at first
the death was attributed to natural
causes he was an epileptic he was in bad
health right no one thought anything
about it until dr. cream [ __ ] Lee
wrote a letter to the coroner and
said that the pharmacist was responsible
for Daniel Scott's death and saying give
me money or I'm going to tell that to
the cops hmm right so this is weird
I know legs but I mean it's like I said
this is like a dumbest like why dramas
emo ever yeah
it's so dumb he just uh you know what's
funny is that during this time there was
a lot of these fake doctors like JJ home
so yeah HH holmes HH holmes that was
yeah he was not now this guy was
actually a real doctor specifically what
he had all the chic and all the
paperwork and [ __ ] and he apparently did
go to colleges and whatnot he just
sounds more like a path lot to a liar
scam artist who yeah he's just like a
frost OSHA path and he was into
murdering right he probably considered
it like euthanasia yeah and where oh
yeah your life your life is unworthy of
living anyway so you didn't hear me put
you out of your misery and maybe made a
buck off yeah I'm trying to make a buck
off here right yeah psycho but so here's
the the dumb thing is that had he not
written a letter to the corner saying
and pharmacist did it hmm no one would
have thought that the Daniel Scott
murder was a murder he figured in
himself that's what I mean all right so
it's almost like he wanted to get caught
yeah just an idiot okay so he got
arrested and it turned out that he was
[ __ ] Daniel Scott's wife what and
that Daniel Scott's wife had asked him
to poison her husband whoa but then she
turned state's evidence and ratted him
out why'd it cream outright jeez
and so I don't know if he thought I
don't know if she had money and he
thought oh we'll bump off the husband
and then you and me I'll share his life
insurer I don't know I don't know if
that's what he thought sounds like a
clue could it could it could this be
more of a case of a quack doctor who is
a sociopath trying to make a buck and
then in the end gets hooked up with a
bad woman who wants to kill her husband
yeah I mean yeah that's because he
doesn't really sound like a typical
serial killer with a sexual motive right
and a drive although I have to say this
is only you know at this point this more
[ __ ] happens oh this is only part yeah
all right but um I don't know this case
yeah you know first of all I'm really
heard about so yeah so she narked on him
now he got sent to mounted so she got
off okay so he got a murder conviction
and this was a Joliet prison in Chicago
he was sentenced to life
however he served I think he served
about ten years
and then his brother um made a
quote/unquote plea for leniency ie
grease some palms sure and and got dr.
creamy let out oh man you could do that
you could get a man out of a life
sentence with a bribe back then Wow yeah
for murder wha of all things
okay so he gets out of Joliet prison hmm
happy as a clam okay then he goes to
England okay
London specifically now he he did not
actually live in Whitechapel and it is
thought that he did not arrive in London
until 1891 which was a couple of years
after the Ripper murders now some people
have said that oh he got out of prison
earlier then then they thought you know
so he could have been there at the time
or a little more far-fetched a couple of
writers have said oh well look-alike
served prison prison in his place or
something I don't know if I really buy
that so you know there's a possibility
he could have been a load as if the
records from the time were a little
spotty so we don't really know so
they're not quite sure but um they think
he was in prison in Chicago when the
murders were going on in London but
they're not entirely certain they think
that he got to he arrived in Liverpool
in 1891 now his father had died and left
him a bunch of money and that's what he
used to move to London it must not have
been a lot of money because he moved to
Lambeth which is kind of a [ __ ] at
the time or you know I don't know if his
bad is Whitechapel but you know same
kind of thing and as soon as he arrived
on British shores he's like I said he
learned nothing learn nothing so as soon
as he got there nineteen year old
prostitute Nelly Don Worth and he
he's like hey he's in a pub want a drink
sure next day she kills her for dead
from strychnine poisoning damn okay
didn't he didn't get anything out of
that I mean I just think oh well
actually actually he did try to get
something out of this same kind of way
he did those he kills a prostitute of
our just giving her drug with strychnine
in it she dies and then when they're
doing the investigation about her death
he did the same thing he wrote a letter
to the coroner and said I know who the
murderer is and I'll tell you for
300,000 pounds what right yeah any and
he wrote a letter to a guy named WFD
Smith who actually if you're from the UK
you'll know WH Smith the bookstore okay
that was one of the original owners
that's a big book chain over there kind
of like Barnes & Noble over here and
accused him of the murder and said give
me money or I'm telling the cops oh man
what a scam right okay son and then it
seemed like he kind of got away with
that one he kind of got identified out
yeah I guess they couldn't really find
out anything about it there was like
whatever and then uh he met with a 27
year old prostitute named Matilda clover
and he did the same thing to her II just
poisoned her yes she died the next day
now this death was not initially thought
a murder because she was an alcoholic
and she was in bad health they thought
she just keeled over dead because her
liver gave out or whatever and it would
have stayed that way again mmm if this
dumbass had not written a letter to
another doctor in town and said I know
you killed her give me money so he's
dead or I'm Braddock yeah and he just
keeps doing it and as far as I know no
one gives him any money for [ __ ] and yet
he's done this at least five six times
and yeah yeah and like I said Miss Mo
does not work well and like it's just a
murder that he was convicted of in
Chicago the murder of Daniel Scott would
have been ruled a natural death if
had not done that and someone had gotten
suspicious and as you'll see the murders
that he did in England the same [ __ ]
happen he would have skated man if he
hadn't done this kind of crap actually
let's take another a wouldn't have
killed the woman had he thought ever had
he what's good way to put it he woulda
killed a woman having had he thought
that or a head he not thought that he
would have made money right but I get ya
so he's dumb enough to think that he's
gonna make money yeah
that's why he killed there's an idiot
didn't learn all right I'm gonna do a
second break real quick right now and
then we'll come back and finish this
case up because this is like funny as
hell
alright so we'll be back in just a
minute there's harro's real and
imaginary and I write about them all
paranormal nonfiction or fiction rush
day laughter guys this mammoth mountain
culture associated monster Red Menace
the patina boy fella whether go to WWJD
AFRICOM or search Amazon for the Jenny
Ashford author page
okay so like I said initially prostitute
Matilda clover they thought she had died
from her alcoholism until cream wrote a
letter to a doctor doctor Broadbent who
was actually a pretty well-known doctor
in the area said you killed her give me
money or I'll tell the cops and doctor
Broadbent being no idiot sent the letter
to Scotland Yard yeah gotcha
as she what he's like what the [ __ ] is
is about it now while that was all going
on there was just like a few days later
and this one was this one was kind of
odd because this one seemed like one
where he didn't try to benefit off it
creams toddling around runs into two
prostitutes because he wanted two for
the price of one I guess we wanted a
challenge this time Alice marsh and Emma
shrivel they were 21 and 18 years old
was able to weasel his way into their
flat okay and he had some bottles of
Guinness hey here you go drink some
Guinness they did he left and then they
both died of strychnine poisoning
several hours later Wow and I don't
think that he attempted to get anything
out of that I guess he just did that one
for shits and giggles madness [ __ ]
freaking thought strychnine took a long
time to kill you you think it does he's
gonna run for help yeah but maybe he's
maybe a dosage was real high yeah that's
my dream maybe they couldn't yeah yeah
heard yeah that's horrible
no necrophilia involved as far as they
know yeah not that it was ever reported
huh unless list of Victorians hadn't
thought of that
oh I'm sure they may have a do you think
that yeah in a lot of ways like if you
read some of the they loved all that
sorted [ __ ] back then I'm sure if
somebody was [ __ ] corpses they'd have
been all about that they had drawn
pictures of it and put in the paper and
I run cuz you know like even during the
Ripper murders they like had those
horrible drawings of like look at all
the intestines and yeah I was kind of
[ __ ]
they were into that so so he kills all
these women and probably
would have just kept doing it and
probably would have got away with it
except for sending all these dumbass
letters pretending to profit off of
something attempting to profit profit
off of it yeah another thing he did -
while he was still free like the face of
constant failure yeah I don't know
anybody I mean the records don't show
whether he ever got any of these people
to be like oh [ __ ] to like give him
money cuz why would you you're like I
didn't kill anybody
why would you give somebody money he's
back at his place why isn't this working
it'll work this time this time it'll
work I know and that's what that's what
cracks me up about this guy it's like
obviously it's horrible he's a horrible
horrible person dumb but stupid yeah
well though like I mean if you're going
to and I'm not at least I have a fetish
maybe it was I mean I'm not advocating
becoming a serial killer anybody I'm not
saying that but it's like if you're
gonna kill people for profit I mean at
least think it through a lot no and if
it doesn't work the first time and you
didn't get caught don't do it like that
again yeah weird that didn't work
another stupid thing he did was um he he
does fantasy prom yeah I did this living
in a world of faces so this uh creme met
up with this policeman that he kind of
knew he was from New York City and cream
was showing the policemen around Lambeth
and he's like hey want me to show you
all the locations of the Lambeth
poisoners oh yeah yeah that's a good one
and and the policeman thought this was
suspicious and he also referred to
Matilda clover one of the women that he
had murdered he referred to it as the
murder of Matilda clover even though at
the time they didn't know she'd been
murdered uh they thought she was you
know it was just an alchemy giveaway
that yeah so he called it a murder and
ever end the policeman was like hmm so
he went to Scotland Yard go yeah this
guy was that a murder yeah was it well
there's a guy here that claims that it
is yeah like and he showed me where all
the victims were he seemed to know a lot
about it right
all right so Scotland Yard were like
okay so they put him under surveillance
they put him under surveillance and they
saw him just toddling around to
prostitutes all day long they also
contacted
the police in Chicago he said oh yeah
that dude was in prison for the emporia
he was supposed to be and he probably
should have still been in there so yeah
we sent him over there to like kill your
people now so now he's your problem so
but finally finally after finding this
out scuttling her finally arrested him
in 1892 and he was actually arrested for
Mathilda clovers murder because he had
pretty much said yeah I murdered her
because they didn't know as a murder at
the time and then later he was charged
with four other murders Nelly Don Worth
Alice marsh and Emma shrivel and also
also an attempted murder so I guess one
of the oh cause one of the prostitutes
he they saw him he picked up one of the
prostitutes and he tried to give her
something to drink hers trying to give
her some pills or something like that
and she got suspicious and shoot him in
the river she threw him in the river no
she threw the pills and okay she threw
the pills in the river because she was
just like she thought he was sketching I
guess right so but um but so he was
charged with the attempted murder there
and he was also charged with extortion
I'll be at the stupidest extortion run
history of extortion and um his defense
was that better be good it's not I sure
enough his defense was I am NOT that
same guy I'm only dr. Thomas Neal I'm
not dr. Thomas Neal cream okay and so
he's trying to say that's not another
guy that there's another guy right with
a name almost like mine yeah and that
was and it's funny because the
newspapers at the time did refer to him
as dr. Thomas Neal but it's that last
name that was his middle name so uh yeah
they so that's a good way that's a good
way to go fund ernie --the the whole
thing though yes identification not me
yeah nothing I mean really that's
probably all he could have done it right
right and he wasn't smart enough to
figure out anything else any good
obviously
so um yeah so he tried that and you know
they saw through that about five seconds
his trial only lasted three days okay
the jury deliberated a grand total of 12
minutes oh yeah that's right yeah and
they're like pre
much nope sorry about that and yeah so
they sent me swingin yeah so they
sentence him to hang yeah and yeah so it
was less than a month later after his
conviction and then they hanged him at
Newgate Prison and then there was the
whole story about I am Jack the Ripper
on the gallows oh yeah but like I said
only the hangman there's only the
hangman's word for that that guy wasn't
smart enough to be the river that no no
and he was just begging for his life he
was trying to delay the execution that
yeah that's and actually we're now here
on the story now then yeah yeah that
actually is what it sounds like maybe he
thought oh if I save that though they'll
do mm no yeah he'll delay it yeah so he
was trying to yeah
[ __ ] so this guy in a way he's come
yeah he's a serial killer in the sense
that he killed at least five people
probably more there was a lot I mean
they think he might have killed his wife
too but he never got pin for that cuz
natural causes but you know how that
goes around him and the weird thing
about him he seems a little different
than George Chapman because like we said
George Chapman didn't really seem to
have any particular motive he didn't get
any financial gain out of anything or
anything like that emotional yeah so I
would think I mean of the two putting
aside the fact that dr. Thomas Neal
cream they thought he might have been in
prison in Chicago at the time of the
Ripper MERS which of course would have
made it impossible for him to be the
Ripper he was actually considered as a
suspect but like he said it doesn't seem
to fit he doesn't seem like I'm not
saying that Jack the Ripper was some
[ __ ] genius or anything like that
mean he must have been kind of funding
at least cuz he never got caught caught
right even though he killed people in
the middle of the street I would say
it's I would say that the the Ripper was
streetwise yeah and dr. cream was it no
no human nature to well no and he was
not and I should say too that he I mean
he wasn't a native of London neither was
George Chapman he was polish but he did
live in that same area so he was
probably familiar with it but um you
know dr. cream had kind of lived all
over he lived in Scotland lived Canada
he lived in the US and then he moved to
London as an adult but he seemed like it
almost seemed like eat it seemed like he
did get some thrill out of poisoning the
women because some of them he did he
just poisoned prostitutes just for the
[ __ ] of it yeah but in most cases it
seemed like he at least tried to get
some kind of yeah financial gain out I
think he was fantasizing that he was
some kind of a brilliant criminal
mastermind but when you domed was a
Zonda to realize that he wasn't and in
the case of the Ripper to be the river
you'd have to be real comfortable in
Whitechapel you have to know it real
well and I guarantee you he was a
regular those would yeah those women
that he knew he he'd probably done
business with them before well yeah
because maybe they wouldn't have felt
threatened that they were gonna miss God
with them yeah and actually even at the
time like I know in in the subsequent
years like pretty much everybody has
been accused of being there I'm
surprised surprised I haven't been
accused of being Jack the Ripper even
though I wasn't even alive I had a time
machine and I went back I'd killed him
Rasta dudes but you know what I mean
everybody was accused but even back then
they said whoever is doing this has
intimate knowledge of Roy Chappel they
are from here I'm gonna up it I'm gonna
say the reason why he got away with it
they're the Ripper he got her what he
got away with it because he was known
and well liked yeah I mean that's why it
wouldn't he was trusted those girls
trusted it yeah that's that because
maybe he was banging prostitutes all the
time and not killing I did not kill them
and then just every now and then he's
just like Oh seems like one of those
days go on murder spree I bet yeah I bet
you and maybe he wasn't a weird al' me
maybe it was pretty normal most of the
time yet somebody that they knew and
liked I think yeah that's how you would
get away with it yeah good no suspicions
right and you know like I said even
though
like I said bring no [ __ ] I'm just
saying that off the top of my head yeah
but you know I would think I would think
that they knew him and liked him yeah I
mean dr. cream was a prostitute guy went
to prostitutes when they had him under
surveillance they said he was [ __ ]
toddle and random prostitutes all the
time or an area but yeah true they
didn't date back then they were either
married or they were going out with
hookers yeah
yeah nothing that was weird is that
these serial killers were killing women
that they were marrying is in those days
and women were desperate to marry they
couldn't work yeah so they didn't have
to be a prowling hunting type serial
killer all-time like you'd have nowadays
yeah you could just marry some chick
yeah kill her and move on married
another one a killer and honestly like I
said would have been a sued killers
paradise really was it honey I mean it
was in many ways and in a lot of ways it
was kind of that was really bad no
particularly in those parts of London
and stuff like that cuz they couldn't
catch you know forensic technology right
exactly a forensic science I mean that's
what I mean it if if circumstances
hadn't intervened some of these guys
might not have been caused over yeah
especially if they were poisoners
because they didn't have any you know
you you could like you said a guy could
just marry a woman yeah he could slowly
poison her it would seem like she died
at consumption or died [ __ ] so we have
people were dying to [ __ ] back then all
the time there was no paperwork no real
bureaucracy that meant anything no DNA
yeah think of printing was new it was
very much in the late eighteen outers
yeah
date criminal databases no communication
between one county in the next one state
the next no federal database yeah so you
all you had to do commit a crime and
move and then forward some documents
yeah herb I forged and it happened over
and over and you could change your
identity on a yearly basis
maybe I mean said look at this doctor
cream idiot he was that he was in prison
for murder in Chicago they let him out
early he moved to London no one knows
anything during that same time you know
people don't realize that the Wild West
was going on it yeah that's new and out
in the West you have guys who would be
robbing trains one month year later
they're the sheriff in a town yes it was
I flew it back
yeah they make both sides and they play
both sides of the law back then yeah
that's true and he might be a good
sheriff that'd be a weird day yeah you
don't well you know with that some of
the skills as a train driver would come
in come in handy to catch criminals of
course I'm gonna do this now for a
living well yeah just look you're using
your expertise right yeah
it's well it's almost kind of like how
they use serial killers that are prison
to catch others a real camera because
who knows better how to think like a
criminal than another criminal I don't
think they do that anymore probably I
think they have profilers now that can
do all that they just gave interview
that they go interview um well I guess
that's kind of like yeah I like helping
but yeah they go interview that that's
how they've come up with profiles is
from interview I think they have a
database I think they know all the ammos
and the certain psychologies behind yeah
like serial killers for the most part
now though I think they've identified
the different types of them yeah
interestingly we we actually since when
we were doing a research for the show we
actually come across this little
documentary I don't know what year was
from it one that old but it was um a guy
who was speculating that it was getting
fritter deeming right who was an
Australian serial killer I think he was
originally from Britain but then he
moved to Australia later and he hacked
up his wife and four kids and they think
that he might have been the Ripper
because his movements were very similar
to oh yeah like he was in the UK when
the murders were going on and then they
stopped when he left and blah-dee-blah
and remember they they said oh we think
we're trying they were trying to get DNA
off the stamp from one of the Jack the
Ripper letters and then and they found
out it was a woman's DNA didn't they I'm
kind of weird well it made sense though
because they thought the women at the
post office bright licked the stamp for
you yeah yeah which could have been that
would have explained that and you know
she could have been deeming I had never
really heard him put forward seriously
until I saw this and I don't know if
that guy was just a crackpot or not but
it was kind of interesting yeah but like
I said you know it was so long ago and
the only reason we're fascinated with it
that well aside from the brutalities
because they never caught the guy never
confident and there were so many
suspects and as so many people it could
have been that there's a lot of serial
killers in arakata you just don't hear
much about it never Scott the original
night soccer I was gonna say so yeah I
did
they've
torn up houses that had dead bodies
underneath them that was that it happens
sometimes during the 20s to the 30s you
know there's like holy [ __ ] we didn't
know about it is even know about it
that's really scary to think about that
there's probably like all kind of
markers that happen that nobody ever I
mean because if no one ever reported you
missing right they in those days yeah if
somebody murdered you you just disappear
yeah you've just languished under
somebody did pretty family that was
looking for you Nate and if your family
could go looking for you but they
couldn't find anything because yeah
State didn't stay tri-counties really
didn't and the thing about serial
killers - is that the reason that it's
so hard to catch them is because they
kill random people ya know connection I
mean you know and that's another thing I
don't advocate this you guys but like
you know if you're gonna commit accrue a
commit a murder murder some [ __ ] you
don't know if you murder somebody you do
know they'll catch you immediately
because it's almost always somebody the
person that's it stranger murder very
rare probably about time yeah we're
coming up to the end of the show I hope
you enjoyed this episode and if you did
please subscribe to our YouTube channel
and go like us on Facebook or follow us
on Twitter we're at 13 o'clock podcast
and is there anything else I usually say
at the end I can't remember huh nope
okay don't don't become serial killers
you guys if you do don't get caught and
we'll see you next week bye
you